foreign
once again my movie review series
so I haven't actually seen all of the
Coen Brothers films uh at this point
I've seen a good portion of them but
honestly like every single one of them
that I've seen has been just uniquely
wonderful and it's in its own right so I
was very excited to see that HBO Max had
put up the Coen Brothers debut film
Blood Simple from 1984. so I was like
really jacked I'm like yeah I'm that
really it's about time that I Revisited
that because I think I saw it once
probably back in the mid 1990s I want to
say and I remembered liking it a lot but
I hadn't watched it again since then and
didn't really remember much about it
other than having just like a general
positive impression of it and I think
like I remembered a few iconic uh shots
particularly like of the end sequence I
have to say though that re-watching it
the movie is every bit as awesome as the
first time I saw it and probably even
more so nowadays because no now I kind
of have the perspective you know I'm
older now and I can appreciate movies
more like I've seen more movies in the
interim and I've seen more of the Coen
brothers movies too so I can really see
since this was their first one you can
really get a good perspective on what
their you know what their start out was
like because there's a lot of stuff in
here that they would utilize again like
later on in their filmography so it's
kind of amazing to think of but Joel and
Ethan Cohen were really not all that
long out of college when they decided to
make Blood Simple now Joel Cohen uh had
in fact recently worked on uh he was an
assistant editor on a little film you
may have heard of it called Sam raimi's
Evil Dead what ended up happening with
that is because Sam Raimi and probably
most horror fans know this but he
actually got funding for the Evil Dead
by making a short film which was kind of
along the same lines and it was called
within the woods and that would
basically be like a trailer that he
could show to potential investors and he
just went around like pounding the pay
pavement looking for people that would
give him money so when the Coen brothers
were like yeah we want to write and do
our own movie um he's like well maybe
that's what you should do you should
make like a trailer and then go around
trying to find people that'll give you
money you know
so that's basically what they did
um they went around they actually made
this kind of short reel it was really
more like a trailer than a short film
um and it actually had fun facts the
legendary Bruce Campbell in it uh and it
was shot by Barry sonnenfeld who had
also just recently graduated from film
school and who would obviously later go
on to become uh you know an amazing
director in his own right he did The
Addams Family movies from the 1990s he
did the Men in Black movies he did get
Shorty he did a bunch of other ones so
basically what the Coen brothers did was
they took this trailer this short film
and they lugged a projector around like
to show this trailer at the houses of
just friends friends of friends
acquaintances anybody who might give
them you know like their dentist or
whatever that might give them like a
little bit of cash to make this movie so
it took him about a year but they ended
up getting uh 1.5 million dollars which
is what they wanted to make the movie so
they put the thing into production it's
kind of like amazing it's very old
school but the fact that they believed
that much in their movie and they were
just willing to basically go ask a bunch
of people for money like going door to
door pretty much I mean is pretty
awesome now for the female lead in the
film uh they initially wanted Holly
Hunter but uh she actually wasn't
available at the time now obviously she
would be in their second film which was
Raising Arizona the Beloved dark
screwball comedy one of my favorite
movies of theirs
um so because she couldn't do it she's
like oh I have this roommate who's also
an actress and her name is Francis
McDormand now Francis McDormand had been
like a stage actress up to this point I
believe Blood Simple was her first
screen appearance and this obviously was
the fact that this happened was pretty
amazing because the Coen brothers would
go on to work with Francis mcdormand's
countless times it's just like a bunch
of times she's probably their most
frequent frequent collaborator uh and
also the whole thing took a personal
turn as well because Francis McDormand
and Joel Cohen got married in 1984 the
same year that this film was released
and they are still married to this day
so that's also pretty awesome now
another story I heard about this movie
is that for one of the main lead roles
they had actually written the role
specifically for the iconic character
actor M Emmett Walsh and so they went to
him and asked him to be in the movie and
he's like look I don't know who the [__]
you guys are I mean they were basically
just out of film school right it's like
there was these two untested youngsters
like asking him to be in a movie and
he's like they're like oh well we'll
give you a percentage of the growth and
he was like [__] that I don't know he
was like this movie might not make any
money and [__] like that so they're like
okay well we'll give you a check every
day he's like I'm not taking a check
from you either so it's like they
basically had to give him like his fee
like every day like in cash that's the
only way he would do it
um which is hilarious that's just I
don't know if that's true but that's a
story I heard so uh this part though
like after the movie came out would
actually get M Emmett Walsh an
independent Spirit award and to be
honest like watching the film again it's
really really hard to imagine this movie
with anybody else in the role because he
just like crushes it he just plays he's
just really Jolly but also really
menacing he's just so so good in this
movie so it's just funny that he was
like so I understand why he was so
reluctant but you know what I mean
so also in the cast we have I mean the
cast is like fairly small there's really
only four or five principal characters
uh you also have John Goetz who would
actually later be in David cronenberg's
uh remake of The Fly among other things
uh Dan hedaya who was also and I
remember him from the Hunger he was like
the police uh investigator in that he
was also in Commando he's been in a
million things too he's like even if you
don't know his name like you've
definitely seen him in something because
he's been in tons of things uh and also
there was the theater and TV actor slash
writer uh Sam Art Williams who I don't
think acted too much in movies after the
early 1990s but he was in this as well
in a fairly small role so the title
Blood Simple actually comes from a line
in the daschal Hammett uh novel red
Harvest which came out in 1929. now this
movie is classed as a neo-noir but it
almost has kind of like a pulp horror
sort of sensibility to it like layered
in with a lot of the classic Noir tropes
which are sometimes kind of like also
upended like in a lot of really
interesting ways like many of the Coen
Brothers other movies because they've
made movies in lots and lots of
different genres and they always have
they like to play with the tropes of
each particular genre that they tackle
and it's all there's always just like
something interesting to see and this
movie is no exception now this movie too
like the influence of Sam Raimi is
pretty apparent especially in some of
the camera movements and if you've seen
the movie there's one particular shot
that's very very that's obviously an
homage to Sam Raimi but I'm gonna have
to say that on the whole
this movie is largely I mean the Coen
Brothers kind of emerging almost fully
formed with their own unique style like
right out of the gate I mean yeah
there's homages to other directors and
Joel and Ethan Cohen are definitely like
students of film and are very like
intellectual in the way that they
approach things but they're doing their
own thing and it's always like really
interesting whatever it is they're doing
so if you're a fan of the Coen Brothers
later films uh watching this movie if
you haven't seen it you will see like
earlier kind of like Echoes or I guess
pre-echos I guess it would be like of
some of their later movies particularly
Fargo
um the man who wasn't there that was
their black and white one with uh with
um Billy Bob Thornton
and uh No Country for Old Men this is
kind of similar to that as well uh like
many of their movies the plots kind of
deal with some half-baked or hair brain
scheme that begins to dramatically
unravel as kind of like a mistake or
misunderstanding builds upon mistake or
misunderstanding until everything has
just gone completely and utterly Fubar
uh there's also that kind of like
trademark Coen Brothers deadpan humor
like it's PR it's fairly understated in
Blood Simple and it's you know
considerably less wacky than their
follow-up which was Raising Arizona but
um it is there nonetheless it's just
very very subdued and like I said very
straightfaced but it's still that kind
of like black humor that they're known
for so in this story Francis McDormand
plays Abby and she is the wife of this
Texas bar owner named Julian Marty who's
playing played by Dan hidea uh he's
almost exclusively referred to by his
last name of Marty so it's pretty clear
from the outset that Marty is kind of a
controlling douche and possibly probably
even abusive and Abby seems like she's
pretty much had enough of his [__] and
she's like well I better get out of here
before I shoot his face off now perhaps
unwisely she chooses to begin an affair
with one of her husband's employees who
is a bartender named Ray who's played by
John Goetz
now Marty is a shitty husband sure but
he is also not stupid so he knows his
wife is up to something and he hires a
private investigator named Lauren Visser
who is MM at Walsh to find out who
exactly it is that she's banging
so visitor starts following Abby around
and like follows Abby and Ray to a motel
and actually starts taking photos of
them like in bed together now the funny
thing about this the kind of like [__]
up thing about this is that Marty did
not actually ask Visser to take pictures
like he didn't he's like I didn't need
to see photographic evidence I just
wanted to find out what was going on and
that kind of like right away Clues you
in like Visser apparently he's just like
oh well that's just a perk of the job
like implying that he's like taking him
for his own personal
advocation I guess uh so that kind of
Clues you in right away that he's kind
of a sleaze and probably dangerous as
well uh you know no matter what his kind
of down-home jovial folksy kind of like
facade would have you believe so when
Rey later on goes back to the bar to
quit like after you know everybody's
found out like what's going on and he's
like look your wife's leaving you and
I'm gonna come back and I quit and I
really need to like collect back to my
last two weeks like his back pay Marty
starts putting the idea in his head that
Abby is just playing him and that she's
eventually going to screw him too and
like not in the fun way now this
ambiguity about Abby's motives like
actually ends up haunting Rey for the
rest of the movie's run time causing a
tremendous amount of suspense as the
couple they just increasingly
miscommunicate and kind of like talk
past each other as events start getting
darker and darker that's kind of one of
the main one of the best things that
generates suspense in the movie is that
you as the audience you kind of know
entirely what it is like what's going on
you're privy to like all this
information you're privy to everyone's
like what they're doing but the
characters don't know so that's kind of
the thing like so like I said that's
what I meant with there's all these like
misunderstandings and stuff like that
because it's just like oh well this
person did that thing I'm like no they
didn't do that thing but that person
thought they did that thing and that
made them do this other thing which
[__] up all this other stuff so that's
kind of like what like I said that's
what causes the tension throughout the
thing is that you know what's going on
but the characters don't so uh Marty
actually attempts to bodily abduct Abby
from Rey's house which seems a little
excessive but Abby uh breaks his finger
like bends his finger way back which is
pretty uh harrowing to watch and gives
him a real solid kick in the balls a
nice one uh and that actually makes him
puke up his lunch in the front yard now
because his uh little ego cannot take
this slate to his manhood evidently he
decides uh that he's going to hire
Visser to kill both Abby and Rey for ten
thousand dollars which seems like quite
a bargain for two murders just saying
so Visser uh who is an opportunist if
there's anything like uh you know he
agrees and he's like well here's what
you do he tells Marty go on a very very
obvious fishing trip tell everybody that
you're going and make sure that while
you're there you're seen by as many
people as possible and I'll take care of
it while you're away so you have an
alibi now when Marty gets back
um you know Visser has already called
him and said yeah it's done
so he meets Visser at his bar to hand
over the cash after Visser produces
photographic evidence this time that
Abby and Ray are dead like there's a
picture of them and they're in bed and
they're all they've shot and everything
but because this event happens that
probably only about the halfway point of
the movie maybe not even that much in
um you just know that it's not going to
be as cut and dried as all that it's
like the end chop John paid uh yeah uh
so what happens then is that viscer
quite unexpectedly uh shoots Marty where
he sits and just leaves him in the bar
for dead
now soon after this we learn that Rey
and Abby are still very much alive and
actually have no idea that Visser took
photos of them sleeping and Doctor them
to make it look as though they'd been
shot just so he could get the money for
killing them without actually having to
you know kill them so from this point
forward the movie becomes just like this
ever more intricate web of
misunderstandings and [__] ups and
double crosses as kind of like like Rey
starts to believe that Abby shot her
husband and then he's like oh well I
have to cover it up for her uh without
telling her you know so there's that
another employee of the bar his name is
Maurice he thinks Rey stole the ten
thousand dollars with the payout from
like the bars safe even though that was
the cover story that Marty gave like to
say where the ten thousand dollars went
so he could cover up you know paying
somebody to kill his wife you know Abby
actually probably doesn't even realize
that Marty is dead and has has no
[__] idea what the hell is going on
even though everybody thinks she does so
it's that viscer too uh starts to become
convinced that he's going to have to
eliminate Abby and Rey from the equation
like to keep his part in the scheme from
being exposed even though really they
don't know who the [__] he is either so
like I said it's just kind of this whole
misunderstanding thing so yeah it's like
this fantastically labyrinthine plot
like just all these mistaken assumptions
on the parts of all the characters which
end up leading of course to tragic
consequences but despite all that like
all the twists and turns it's still
pretty straightforward and like pretty
easy to follow
and one event follows very logically and
very naturally on from the last and the
movie is also I have to say just like
perfectly paced I mean it just keeps up
the tension like all throughout the 96
Minutes it's just a very very taut
Thriller and it just kind of like keeps
you on the edge of your seat like the
whole time I have to say too I also love
the score for this uh it was done by
Carter Burwell this was actually his
first uh of many scores that he did he
worked with them a lot like later on
it's very it's it's a very simple piano
score it's very moody it's very somber
and I really really like it
um it also has the the movie also has
like a good but you know judicious use
of like some cool songs there's like
four tops Patsy Cline like stuff like
that that's in there so that's kind of
cool too but I really do love that
background piano score now much like uh
several of the Coen Brothers later films
as well Blood Simple also has just long
stretches of screen time with no
dialogue but you'll be seriously you'll
be too riveted to like the action that's
going on to even noticed that nobody is
talking
um I mean you know I didn't notice and
it also makes a great use of a lot of
your Thriller tropes um has a few
moments of like real Grim like brutality
like I said like almost a horror movie
kind of sensibility and has a few like
well-placed jump scares too if you've
seen it you know like the whole
newspaper hitting the door which like
scared the absolute [__] out of me I was
just like what the [__] was that it's
just like I jumped off my [__] seat
but yeah and the whole final sequence of
this like with Abby and uh Visser is
just terrifying it's really really
suspenseful really done well and uh also
the whole thing ends with a piece of
just real delicious irony uh that kind
of just puts the chef's kiss on top of
the whole shebang so yeah so even though
I hadn't seen it since the 90s uh in my
opinion Blood Simple really hasn't dated
at all
um it's still like a really great
masterful Thriller neo-noir with some
horror movie like kind of stuff in it
that I mean anybody that's into the Coen
Brothers later stuff you should
absolutely dig it like I said if you
have HBO Max it's on there that's where
I watched it I think it's on Amazon
Prime as well but I don't know if you
have to pay to rent it or not but I did
see that it was on there but yeah it's
really really great and if you haven't
seen it then you definitely should I
liked it a lot and probably so will you
if you've seen it let me know in the
comments what you thought about it and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear I'll see you guys again on the next
one bye
[Music]
foreign